OK, let's get into audience questions for
the week.
Many of them related to the really tragedies
that we observed in the United States over
the last week and a half.
First question, David.
We have the biggest military and most militarized
police in the world.
Why couldn't the Capitol Police keep rioters
out?
What the hell happened?
And this is a question that became an important
one very quickly after we as we were witnessing
the events of January 6th, the riotous insurrection
fomented by President Donald Trump.
And it is true, the government spends hundreds
of billions on defense, on the military, Department
of Defense, Pentagon to Department of Homeland
Security, on and on and on.
How is it possible that you ended up with
a situation where a mob reaches the Capitol,
the vice president and members of Congress
are are there Secret Service and other evacuations?
And and within minutes, this mob I mean, we
were watching it.
And it wasn't very long after the debate started
into the objections over Arizona that the
mob had overrun the building and people needed
to take shelter and on and on.
So there are two big picture answers and we'll
dig into each of them.
One big picture answer is they didn't understand
the scope of the threat.
The other big picture answer is they understood
the scope of the threat and chose not to be
more prepared.
And there's a sort of more benign, at least
as motives go, explanation for that and the
more conspiratorial one.
So let's start with the most conspiratorial,
because I'm not going to spend a lot of time
of it absent evidence.
And the conspiratorial version would be everybody
knew exactly what was going to happen.
And the reason police weren't prepared is
because police say whoever is in power, we're
in on a plan to allow this to happen for whatever
reason, to make someone look good or make
someone look bad or to suggest a pretext for
Trump to declare martial law.
That's the conspiratorial conspiratorial when
police were in on it.
And so far, I've not seen evidence of that.
I don't attribute malice one.
Incompetence adequately covers what we've
seen.
So then we get to the Capitol Police didn't
know what to expect versus they knew what
to expect and just didn't didn't prepare enough.
There are reports about the Capitol Police
rejecting some federal offers for help, both
in advance of an in the moment of what was
going on.
It still has to be investigated.
And if it's true that Capitol Police rejected
further offers of help, then that's a disaster
and it has to be investigated.
Why did the leadership refuse the help?
What are the explanations?
And that needs to be looked at.
And then the other side of it would be they
simply didn't realize the risk that was posed
and they were caught unprepared.
And that also requires an investigation because
we're talking about securing the capital when
the vice president is going to be there at
a time crucial to American democracy.
So either way, it would be a failure.
We just have to have to figure it out now
from a very, you know, logistical wrote perspective.
A lot of this has to do with lack of enough
perimeters.
And, you know, there's just crowd control
stuff like I don't know if people are looking
for an answer that's very specific to crowd
control, but when you have such a large crowd,
it has to be managed earlier.
It is true that Trump hesitated and ultimately
it seems he was even Mike Pence who sent the
National Guard once things were going on.
It is true that it took a while for state
troopers from Virginia and others show up
to show up.
That's all true.
But the reality is it's already too late at
that point to try to retake control of a scene
when it has already degenerated to what it
had degenerated at that point in time by one
forty one fifty p.m. Eastern Time on Wednesday.
It's too late.
Large crowds of protesters have to be managed
earlier.
The capital should have been surrounded and
secured earlier with multiple perimeters.
And in addition to that, the crowds should
have been directed even when they were blocks
away.
They should have been redirected.
And that's the only way you can manage and
direct a crowd that large because it didn't
happen.
The protesters were able to start congregating
in large groups already close to the capital.
And then you had another failure, which was,
as we saw the barriers breached still, you
know, kind of far from the capital.
At that point, the number of officers left
on the Capitol steps was too small to control
what was happening.
And so the perimeter was pushed further back.
So some of the analyzes we've seen are that
it was completely unthinkable not to have
multiple layers of police cordons on the.
Outskirts of the complex and even further
out, fences and barricades, there were some,
but they're useless.
Unless you're properly directing the crowd,
you have to start making arrests early.
Very importantly, understand that when the
first people started battling with the officers
at the barriers near the Capitol, yes, there
weren't nearly enough officers.
And yes, they never should have been that
close in groups that large.
But nobody got arrested.
And you could say, well, the police were overwhelmed.
How can they start arresting people right
away?
It's fair.
It was all completely mismanaged.
But one of the things you want to do is you
need to start making the arrests early.
You need to immediately target the people
that seem most violent.
Some of the people that were earliest, most
violent on video, they stuck around for hours
and eventually made it into the Capitol.
So everything everything that happened was
done wrong.
By the way, I'm speaking in defense of the
officers in the sense that early there were
people already being violent with the officers,
hitting them with the barriers themselves.
The people being violent with officers need
to be arrested right away.
And they weren't.
So everything went wrong.
The motives and explanations, we still don't
know.
But from a logistical crowd control standpoint,
everything went wrong in the sense that none
of the stuff that should have been done was
done.
And we'll learn more about it, I'm sure, in
two months when some report is published that
nobody will see but will pay attention for.
And we'll take
a look at